notre fit du jour c'est donc cette
colère qui gronde à La Verrière morpa
éloncour mais aussi à coignère ces
quatre communes qui s'unissent afin
d'obtenir de meilleurs horaires des
trains par exemple mais aussi une
rénovation de la gare de La Verrière
George B a fait le premier invité de
cette édition je le disais tout à
l'heure ma adjoint morpa délégué aux
travaux président du Collectif des
usagers de la verrière vous allez vous
joindre rejoindre en tout cas les les
différents mères qui de appel à cette
mobilisation devant la garde de la
verrière on va évoquer cette
mobilisation mais tout d'abord
expliquez-nous vos grifs que
reprochez-vous à cette gare de la
verrière et à son organisation il y a
10000 usagers par jour qui passe là-bas
alors la gare de La Verrière ce sont
10000 usagers par jour il y avait il y
avait déjà eu un certain nombre de
mobilisations enfin d'actions engagées
depuis 2010 et 2011 il y a eu des
pétitions il y a eu un certain nombre de
choses de fait et par rapport à cette
action donc le il y a un premier constat
c'est une politique d'abandon de cette
gare par les services publics c'est une
gare qui qui est inadaptée au flux aux
différents flux journaliers alors
particulièrement d'usagers des
transports mais également
de aux alentours de la gare des
installations vitust donc je pense que
vous aurez l'occasion de revenir dessus
et puis il y a un certain nombre de de
retard dans les dans les grands projets
notamment un projet qui est demandé
depuis très nombreuses années qui est la
prolongation de du rerc jusqu'à coenère
parce qu'il s'arrête il s'arrête un peu
plus haut
voilà voilà c'estàdire qu'aujourd'hui
par rapport à l'offre ferroviaire donc
on a la on a le rerc qui s'arrête à 50
en iveline on a la ligne de la de la
défense qui s'arrête à la verrière et
après donc il y a la ligne A qui descend
jusqu'à jusqu'à Rambouillet et ce qui
fait que ça crée des nœuds comme ça de
d'interconnexion et de de de convergence
c'est-à-dire que les usagers par exemple
qui vont à la défense ils viennent
plutôt prendre le train à La Verrière
que dans d'autres gares pour éviter le
pour éviter le le le changement de un
changement de train est- ce qui fait que
ça crée des ça crée des justement des
convergences importantes et ça crée en
plus de un afflux de de passagers qui
peut-être pourrait prendre le train dans
d'autres gores alors ce que nous
demandons à la à la SNCF en particulier
c'est la mise en accessibilité de la
gare avant 2015 là on est sur les normes
handicap hein oui oui sur les par
rapport aux normes handicap c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui alors en tant qu'él aux
travaux je suis directement concerné
puisque on a attaché une grande
importance à mettre l'ensemble de la
ville au aux normes d'accessibilité
d'ailleurs MPa a eu le premier prix
d'accessibilité pour la voirie
dernièrement et donc nous demandons
qu'il en soit de même pour les
établissements recevant du public donc à
usage enfin c'est c'est public mais
c'est privé quand même qui a la garde
qui a la gare avant 2015 avec sa
rénovation parce que la gare a plus de
40 ans hein le réétablissement de la
vente de billet grande ligne qui a
disparu aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que si
quelqu'un veut acheter un billet grand
ligne il est obligé de venir à 50
nieline qui représente quand même une
distance de 10 km et donc le
prolongement du RORC jusqu'à coignère
voilà pour les différentes
revendications la réorganisation de ce
Grand Paris il en a beaucoup été
question he ces derniers mois ces
dernières années avec ce ce projet qui
avait été lancé sous Nicolas Sarkozi qui
a trouvé son sa conclusion il y il y a
quelques semaines quelques mois pour
autant dans un récent communiqué vous
nous dites les habitants du Sud iblblin
sont à nouveau les grands oubliés c'est
qu'il n'y a aucun changement avec ce
projet du du Grand Paris de
réorganisation on n pas pensé à ce
secteur de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
cette partie des Yvelines tout à fait
alors on a moi j'ai étudié avec beaucoup
d'attention ce projet du Grand Paris qui
part quand même d'un d'un sur le fond
d'un bon sentiment puisque justement ça
permettait de faire des liaisons
transversales qui ont disparu depuis
depuis quelques nombreuses années
maintenant et donc on s'aperçoit que le
projet s'arrête peut-être à 50 ans
yeline et encore c'est même pas sûr
repart après sur le plateau de sa clé et
après sur le sur le sudiveline prend le
sudiveline parce qu'on est plus concerné
ENF derrière mais il y a aussi y a
également d'autres dessertes qui sont un
petit peu oubliés c'est-à-dire que il y
a il il y a pas de de projet ou pas de
visibilité sur des projets justement
soit
d'interconnexion d'interconnexion de
réseau ou d'amélioration des réseaux en
fait alors que pensent les usagers de
cette garde son état veulent-ils des
prolongements de ligne nous sommes allés
vous poser la question micro trottoir à
certaines heures de pointe ou il y a ou
à certaines horaires tels que à partir
de 10h comme ça il y a pas c train il y
a pas mal de retard en ce moment des des
trains supprimés retardés mais sinon ça
va
pour être à l'heure ils sont à l'heur
c'est plutôt la sécurité oui sécurité
oui parfois de temps en temps la
ponctualité mais c'est surtout la ligne
de mon Parnasse la ligne de la défense
ça va ça se passe bien bah la ligne la
verrière elle a souvent des problèmes
c'est c'est sal c'est ça il y a certains
choses on voit s'il y avait plus de
surveillance dans ce domaine là je crois
que ça améliorait beaucoup de choses pas
trop propre des fois quand on r en train
ça sent la piss ou il y a de la des
poubelles partout pas assez de train
pour nous c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable qu'à moins
de je m pas on a 50 km de Paris et qu'on
metre 45 minutes pour arriver à la
défense infernale quoi certains usagers
qui sont très remontés on parle aussi de
problèm de sécurité vous les avez
constater oui oui alors pas les
problèmes de en fait des problèmes de
sécurité ou d'insécurité sont souvent
des problèmes d'insécurité perçus
justement par rapport à la vitusité des
équipements d'cord on se sent en
sécurité dans un c'est vieux et comme
c'est vieux ça donne un sentiment un
sentiment d'insécurité perçu même si
c'est pas forcément forcément la la la
réalité on voit ça dans dans certains
ouvrages juste pour compléter je sais
pas si vous me permettez on était enfin
le collectif était déjà intervenu dans
le passé pour demander une accélération
du remplacement des trains sur la ligne
N qui maintenant on 60 ou 70 ans euh
également donc par rapport au projet
d'infrastructure puisque il y a la
problématique ferroviaire mais il y a
également tout ce qui tourne autour y
compris les dessertes donc les les voies
d'accès alors là ça me concerne plus et
c'est là où je voulais envenir ça tombe
bien ça concerne pas uniquement ni le
STIF la région qui organise les lignes
de train ça ça concerne plus directement
communauté d'agglomération pour tout ce
qui est route aménagement notamment la
ville de morpa la ville de La Verrière
aussi ville de morpa ville de la
verrière qui se réunissent et l'en
courour aussi au sein d'un d'un
collectif donc je vous le redis demain
matin si vous croyez les élus c'est tout
simplement qu'ils viendront à la
rencontre des usagers pour faire signer
cette pétition pour interpeller le le
président de la SNCF mais au-delà de ça
est-ce que les discussions entre ces
différentes communes s'engagent aussi
pour résoudre les problèmes qui sont
directement de leur ressort à morpa par
exemple vous avez engagé des discussions
avec les autres communes pour
l'aménagement pour les routes alors à
morpa il y a eu des enfin parce que le
projet remonte déjà à 15 ans ou à 20 ans
donc il y a eu c'était un peu à
répétition donc il y a eu des comment
dire ça s'appelle un comité de pôle
c'est-à-dire un regroupement de
différentes institutions ou instances
qui a été créé pendant donc à une époque
et qui était chargé justement de la
promotion de ce projet puisqueil faut
savoir quand même que mourpa a une
particularité c'est que SAG se trouve
sur la commune d'à côté donc on est
directement concerné on a on a une
passerelle n pas forcément facile
pueffectivement il y a voilà de voix
seulement pour permettre d'y passer
enfin deux fois une voie oui et et où
c'est un petit peu compliqué
c'est-à-dire que vous avez des heures un
petit peu difficiles où c'est l'heure où
tout le monde va où travaille et donc il
y a pas de comme il y a pas de
dissociation des réseaux ça fait que
tous les bus se trouvent pris dans les
embouteillages du matin et donc ça crée
encore des difficultés supplémentaires
parce qu'il y a des gens qui ratent
leurs train parce qu'ils sont que ça va
changer alors pouveit donner une bonne
nouvelle à rassurer un petit peu en tant
qu'élu de alors quand même quand même
une bonne nouvelle parce qu'il y a pas
il y a pas que des mauvaises nouvelles
quand même une bonne nouvelle donc il y
a eu il y a eu une avancée dernièrement
donc ça remonte à fin fin de l'année
dernière début de cette année où il y a
eu justement l'annonce du redémarrage du
projet de enfin déjà doublement du pont
d'accès à la gare c'est-à-dire la remise
en deux fois de voix avec le
réaménagement du pôle multimodal
c'està-dire avec la gare routière alors
on n' pas encore d'échéance ça se fera
vraissemablement aux horizons
2017-28 mais au moins il y a déjà une
perspective alors qu'avant il y avait
pas de perspective et donc si on met ça
plus alors nous on comptait un peu sur
la justement la remise en en
accessibilité de la gare d'ici 2015 donc
des mise en accessibilité on pouvait
imaginer qu'il y avait quelques travaux
qui étaient donc ça aurait fait ça
aurait fait un projet un peu global et
un peu cohérent qui aurait donné redonné
une dynamique à ce quartier enfin c'est
pas vraiment un quartier mais cette zone
cette zone d'activité demain il y aura
une mobilisation des différ él votre
collectif va également y participer
est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres actions qui
sont prévues pour conclure comment vous
allez vous organiser il y a aussi des
échéances municipales donc on imagine
que les dossiers vont pas bouger dans
les prochains mois mais en tout cas
qu'ils vont faire parler puisque les
différents candidats vont devoir se
positionner sur ces dossiers très
attendus par la population tout à fait
alors comment vous allez vous organiser
avec le collectif alors par rapport au
collectif donc nous nous jeux dire
revendication on peut dire ça comme ça
sont son relativement clair il faut
savoir que MPa ne porte pas la plus
grande part part du projet puisque les
projets sont principalement rattachés à
la ville nouvelle de 5 en Yveline
toutefois on demandera enfin aux élus de
la prochaine de la prochaine majorité
donc à être très attentif au bon
déroulement de ces projets fer peut-être
partie d'ailleurs peut-être parce que là
vous êtes dans cette majorité tout à
fait tout à fait on peut aussi imaginer
que les gens vous demandent un petit peu
de d'en parler un petit peu plus et de
rendre des comptes sur ce dossierl on
verra comment ils vont réagir demain ne
serait-ce que sur la mobilisation en
garde la verrière merci à vous
d'être venu sur ce plateau merjint à
morpa mobilisation demain en gare de La
Verrière le matin le soir des élus un
collectif pour accueir les usagers
évoquer ce dossier de réhabilitation
d'Ar